[Music]  [Music]  so once you get back  to new york about a week it doesn't open  up  the apartment building where i'm working  not quite as excited as where you've  been  it sounds just fine  we'll use the next two days to get you  acclimated get the weekend off we come  back to work on monday i think you can  handle that  i'll do my best  shall we begin  [Music]  hey what's going on hey who are you i  promise our visit would be  as brief as humanly possible  [Music]  for me the building would be empty it's  nothing to worry about i'll handle it  [Music]  what's a decorated soldier doing here as  a doorman  [Music]  [Music]  they're here you have to be  it's a bloody rembrandt  [Music]  you should walk away now and if you  don't i will take you to hell  all my voices will call you up  [Music]  you